I was out in California a couple weeks
ago and I rented a car and I experienced
sticker shock as to not the price of
that warranty they wanted to sell me
insurance but rather the price of gas it
was just under five bucks a gallon for
premium in some parts of California
obviously I would never put premium in a
rental car what do I care right I'm just
giving it back in two days but then when
I got back to Massachusetts even though
gas prices here are much lower I noticed
that they were up here as well and
indeed gas prices have now hit a
three-year high this often becomes an
expensive time of year for gas prices
sort of the pre summer period the
national retail average price for gas is
two dollars and 81 cents per gallon once
again highest price in three years now
gas prices cycle up and down all the
time but this is interesting because
this is one of those political footballs
right gas prices are one of those things
where if the price goes up and the guy
you like is in the Oval Office you say
presidents don't influence gas prices
and if prices of gas go up and someone
you don't like is in the Oval Office you
blame them for the high gas prices now I
would never do that Pat I've been
consistent on this during the Bush era
during the Obama era and I plan to
continue in the Trump era which is the
reality that presidents have some
indirect responsibility for gas prices
although they are more generally
dictated by economic factors that they
do relate to White House policy but it's
not a totally direct connection and the
reason that right now we're seeing gas
prices go up is because of a number of
different factors limited international
production capacity there's some
question about political instability in
the Middle East where lots of the crude
oil comes from that's used to make
gasoline the possibility of a conflict
between Iran and Saudi Arabia which
Trump does actually have some connection
to is also a factor and then seasonality
is also a factor and there's a couple of
interesting things about gas prices in
this conversation number one is that for
most people except people who drive for
a living or have really long commutes
most people don't change their behavior
because of a modest or even moderate
change in gas prices like imagine
someone who drives a thousand miles a
month right that's usually what you get
on a normal
it's 12,000 miles a year and your car
gets the average gas mileage 24 miles
per gallon I think 23.6 is the average
for US cars and light trucks call it 24
if you drive a thousand miles a month 24
miles per gallon $2 a gallon gas you
spend 83 dollars a month and gas if gas
prices go up 50 percent from $2 a gallon
to $3 a gallon you're spending an extra
42 dollars per month it's not nothing
but for most people your driving
behavior isn't going to change over 42
dollars a month assuming the driving
you're doing is necessary driving maybe
if you're gonna buy a new car like if
you would have considered an SUV you'll
get a Prius instead but that's about it
when you have higher gas prices new new
car sales tend to go in the direction of
more fuel-efficient cars which arguably
is good I Drive like 700 miles a month
my car gets like 30 miles per gallon so
when it gas goes from 2 to 3 bucks it's
$24 a month for me I only do necessary
driving so I'm not gonna change my
behavior where it really matters is
products that are shipped by truck and a
ton of the stuff we buy including our
food is shipped by truck and that is an
industry that is hugely sensitive to gas
prices so the impact of a gas price
increase is that our goods can start to
cost more this is one of those things
that's often not really discussed in the
context of gas prices so what I'm
curious to hear from people in our
audiences have you changed your driving
behavior because of these three year
record high gas prices if you have let
me know if you haven't also let me know
and I suspect that that other than the
truckers who are in our audience most
people have not been affected by the
change in prices not yet maybe if it
goes up to $4 a gallon they would be
that's it
I also worried that this could be a
bellwether for a recession coming up
obviously you can't really ever predict
the state of the economy going forward
yeah but I remember in 2007 which was
like a year before the Great Recession
started sure gas went up to like well
over 100 oil went up to like over $100 a
barrel yes and it looks like we may be
heading in that direction now too
although I mean to play devil's advocate
that was also as the mortgage crisis was
exploding so there are arguably other
things going on
we would hope at least to the extent
that we know aren't going on right now
send me your thoughts about the gas
price increase we have a great bonus
show for you today we'll talk about
Facebook ranking news organizations and
much much more
get access to the bonus show by becoming
a patron for five bucks a month or by
becoming a member at join pakman.com
today's episode of the program is made
possible in part by Cody a new
innovative cryptocurrency and online
payment platform that's setting out to
revolutionize how payments are sent and
received online what Cody stands for is
currency of the internet and most
Kryptos out there today simply weren't
designed for online payments and the
goal of the Cody crypto is to achieve an
infrastructure for online payments that
simple transparent trustworthy
instantaneous and scalable which no
blockchain for payments has really
achieved to date so Cody is aiming to be
that missing piece of the puzzle a
crypto and platform actually designed
with online payments in mind if you're
watching this on youtube you can find
out more about Cody and their ICO by
using the links below the video this is
not financial advice and should not be
interpreted as such and everybody should
do their own research on any project
that they're interested in